>> Laura: AN UNBELIEVABLE
STORY, GOOGLE HAS A LOT OF
EXPLAINING TO DO.
IF YOU GOOGLE THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THE
INFORMATION BLOCK WOULD INFORM
YOU ABOUT THE PARTY'S IDEOLOGY.
WHAT IT SAID WAS JAW-DROPPING.
LET'S EXAMINE IT WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY, REPUBLICAN FROM
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU MAJORITY
LEADER McCARTHY.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
GOOGLE SAID THIS WAS A MISTAKE,
BUT YOU GOT WIND OF THIS.
WHEN YOU TYPED IN CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN PARTY, WHAT SHOWED
UP?
>> IT'S AT OUR IDEOLOGY WAS A
NAZISM.
IT WASN'T A PARTY OF LINCOLN, IT
WASN'T THE PARTY OF REAGAN, IT
SAID WE WERE.
GOOGLE IS THE LARGEST SEARCH
ENGINE IN THE WORLD.
90% OF SEARCH ENGINES GO THROUGH
GOOGLE.
AND I GOT WIND OF THIS, AND, I
WENT OVER TO WIKIPEDIA FOR
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICANS AND IT
DID NOT SAY IS.
IT IT CONCERNS ME GREATLY
BECAUSE THE BIAS THAT IS
HAPPENING HERE, IF YOU SEARCHED
ON INSTAGRAM FOR
DONALD TRUMP JR. THIS WEEKEND,
YOU KNOW WHAT IT TOLD YOU?
THEY WARNED YOU THAT THE SITE
COULD CAUSE YOU HARM OR EVEN
DEATH.
THEN THEY CAN THE ARMY KICKED
OFF THE ALLIANCE FOR FREEDOM TO
GIVE THEIR CHARITY PROGRAM,
AMAZON SMILE.
IF YOU WERE PERCHING DUMB LIKE
PURCHASING SOMETHING THERE YOU
COULD SEND A CHARITY MONEY TO A
NONPROFIT.
THEY REMOVE THEM BECAUSE A
SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW DECIDED
THEY WERE GOOD.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO DEFEND RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM BEFORE THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> Laura: THAT CENTER HAS
TURNED INTO A LEFT WING RABID
RADICAL GROUP THAT TRIES TO
MALIGN PEOPLE, MYSELF INCLUDED,
BECAUSE WE STAND UP AGAINST
CHRISTIANS BEING PERSECUTED IN
THE MIDDLE EAST AND I WE ARE
ANTI-ISLAM.
OKAY, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
SO WHAT CAN BE DONE?
GOOGLE SAID THEY BLAME
WIKIPEDIA, AND THEY USUALLY
CATCH VANDALISM BEFORE IT
IMPACTS SEARCH RESULTS.
BUT OCCASIONALLY ERRORS GET
THROUGH AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
>> THEY GAVE THAT I EXPLANATION
AFTER WE WENT FORWARD IN PUBLIC
WITH IT.
BUT I HAD ALREADY SEARCHED
WIKIPEDIA AND IT WASN'T ON THE
WIKIPEDIA PAGE.
THIS IS WHY WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY.
THIS BIAS AGAINST CONSERVATIVES
HAS TO STOP.
AND THEY ALWAYS EXPLAIN IT AWAY
WITH SOMETHING SMALL.
NO, I WANT TO KNOW, DID AN
EMPLOYEE IN THEIR GO FORWARD AND
PUT THE IDEA THAT THE PARTY OF
LINCOLN THAT BROUGHT US
RONALD REAGAN, THE DECIDED WE
WERE?
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Laura: IT'S A LIBERAL
CULTURE THERE IN SILICON VALLEY
AND CERTAINLY AT GOOGLE.
LET'S MOVE ONTO OTHER TOPICS.
LOTS OF CONVERSATION ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT WHO WILL BE
THE NEXT SPEAKER.
HER NAME IS ALWAYS AT THE TOP OF
THE LIST, BUT YOUR FRIENDS OVER
THERE AT THE "LOS ANGELES TIMES"
SAID, WHY CALIFORNIA KEVIN
McCARTHY IS HAVING A HARD TIME
WALKING DOWN THE SPEAKER'S JOB
AGAIN.
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
MY CAREER AS A CONGRESSMAN FROM
NORTH CAROLINA'S NAME MENTIONED,
WHO I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
WE HAVE OTHER PEOPLE'S NAMES
MENTIONED BUT, WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> WELL ONE, THERE IS NO
SPEAKER'S RACE.
PAULINE DECIDED HE IS NOT
RUNNING FOR REELECTION, SO AFTER
THE ELECTION WE WILL HAVE ONE.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A REPUBLICAN TO BE A
SPEAKER.
I'M VERY CONFIDENT GOING FORWARD
MY WHOLE GOAL RIGHT NOW IS
MAKING SURE WE WIN THE MAJORITY.
THAT'S WHY I'M TRAVELING THE
COUNTRY, DEFENDING THE
INDIVIDUALS AND MAKING SURE WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO WIN.
BECAUSE REMEMBER WHAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH, UNEMPLOYMENT
AT AN 18 LOW.
WE HAVE REFORMED THE VA.
THE RIGHT TO TRY.
THE SICK INDIVIDUALS HAVING A
SUCCESS.
WE ALSO DID THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE, THAT WAS JUST THAT
WEEK.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO T
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO TO
AN AMNESTY?
FICO KNOWN.
WE ARE GOING TO PROTECT OUR
BORDERS BECAUSE WE KNOW AND YOU
KNOW SO WELL THE IDEA OF THE
CURRENT SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IS
BROKEN.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO COME UP
ONE, BUILD A WALL.
WE HAVE TO END CATCH AND
RELEASE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS
BASED ON MERIT IF WE REALLY WANT
THIS COUNTRY TO GROW.
>> Laura: DOES JOHN COX HAVE A
CHANCE IN CALIFORNIA?
DOES THE G.O.P. HAVE A REASON TO
HOPE IN CALIFORNIA?
>> YES.
REMEMBER THIS IS THE STATE THAT
BROUGHT US RONALD REAGAN.
WE HAVE THIS CRAZY SYSTEM WHICH
I DO NOT LIKE.
THIS IDEA IS CRAZY.
JOHN COX WILL COME THROUGH BUT
THERE IS ANOTHER REASON FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE HOPEFUL.
THE DEMOCRATS WHEN THEY TOOK THE
MAJORITY, THEY RAISE THE
GASOLINE TAX $0.12.
THEY HAVE INITIATIVE ON THE